aujourd'hui en france 13 millions de
personnes éloignées
c'est en partant de ce constat que
google a décidé de lancer son challenge
en france des prix récompensant des
projets valorisants l'inclusion
numérique juive ni aux intérêts savons
qu'il ya des organisations vraiment
innovant qui s'y qui ont des idées pour
savoir être à proximité de l'inclusion
et on voulait être à côté des meilleures
idées des entrepreneurs à travers le
pays est procuré l'aide dont ils ont
besoin et de trouver au mieux des
volontaires pour google parmi les 250
candidatures dix projets ont été retenus
finalistes chaque représentant avait une
minute trente pour séduire le jury et 3
minutes 30 pour répondre à leurs
questions parmi eux deux centres de
formation active dans les yvelines
o'clock une école qui forme au métier de
développeur web via des classes
virtuelles
c'était vraiment un gros travail à la
hauteur de l'enjeu aussi le pitch était
aussi beaucoup de stress mais bon
maintenant maintenant que c'est passé on
peut en parler de manière assez apaisés
on est on est tous content de l'avoir
fait et ouais force 3 pour son programme
de formation numérique dédié aux
personnes en situation de handicap
s'ils ne font pas partie des cinq
lauréats comme tous les finalistes
il remporte tout de même une dotation de
150 mille euros je pense que ce qui va
être très important c'est que en plus de
la subvention
de manière égale pour les dix quand les
dix lauréats il va y avoir du mécénat de
compétences de google et dans notre cas
c'est assez important parce qu'on a
besoin d'une aide sur le plan
technologique pour construire ce
dispositif
andy ward sièges les deux grands
gagnants sont le carillon qui propose
des solutions d'accès au numérique pour
les sans domicile fixe prix du public et
connexions qui aide les personnes en
recherche d'emploi à accéder aux
compétences numériques premier prix du
jury